nevin what's going on so basically my
question is
uh how to deal with a grief
question um i lost
my son firstborn son here about
oh five five years ago
in 2015 and i'm so sorry and
it was a stillbirth and then we did have
a
healthy little girl a couple years later
and then
here two years ago i lost
my next son to a complicated messed up
pregnancy and anyway my wife
is ready to move on and
try again but i guess
it's one of those things where i
i'm just ready to
hang it up on pregnancy yeah pretty
hesitant man
yeah well hey dude thanks for sharing
that i know that's hard to talk through
that
um tell me about your tell me about the
your two boys that passed away what were
their names
uh my first firstborn his name was
jackson yeah
and the one that just passed two years
ago
hudson beautiful man tell me about your
daughter
uh tavia she's my little firecracker
about four and a half right now yeah
into everything
just as she should be man i have a
firecracker four-year-old too that's
into everything man
um how did you and your wife grieve
these losses
well the first law
was an absolute shock yeah
we everything was progressing normally
at 38 weeks
there got only uneasy when we didn't
feel movement
went in for an ultrasound and no
heartbeat and
and so that one went down we we took
heart
right and then but then with uh
with hudson we knew early on in the
pregnancy that there was
some major issues and so we were kind of
able to
over the course of the pregnancy kind of
how we
i mean we knew there was very slim
chance of
survival for the child but we wanted to
give him every chance
yeah and then when when he was actually
born
um his abdomen was oak was open and
closed up
and he actually bled to death um
before they couldn't do anything and the
only response i got out of him
was when he was born i took his hand and
kind of squeezed my finger a little bit
and
his heart beat he never took a breath on
his own his heart beat for about 20
minutes
and then yeah that was you still feel
that squeeze every once in a while don't
you
yeah yeah so
after after the fact two months three
months six months later
that grief is still with you what does
it look like in your wife and what does
it look like with you
well i'm not sure exactly how i'm
supposed to answer that
did y'all just go but did you go back to
just the way things were was your wife
just automatically planning all right
well here's the next thing or
um did you start drinking a lot hang out
with your buddies did you find it hard
to wake up like what did what did
being sad what did owning this
this just suck what did that look like
in your home
well for my wife
um i think
she probably took it the hardest at the
beginning
but um but yeah i think she probably did
hang out with her friends a little more
okay um for me
i've had a little bit of a tough time
oh i mean i have a couple close
friends but we've kind of drifted apart
over the last
year or so and i'm not i'm not really
close with anybody at the moment
okay but so here's the thing
few things can disrupt and fracture a
family
like mismatch grief or comparative grief
and sometimes somebody just
shuts it down for months when they lose
somebody when they lose a pregnancy when
they lose a parent when they lose
a spouse they shut it down other people
go into meaning making mode and they
just start creating businesses and
things
and getting fit and they deal with it
over the next four or five years
and some people fill in the blank some
people do something else some people do
something else
but if your wife went and met with
people and grieved and
wept and wrote letters and talked and
met with a counselor
and you just went to work and then you
just went to work and then you just went
to work
and i'm just making this up man okay
well you're hitting it on the head
okay at some point i would step back and
say
she's gonna be way further down the road
of not getting over it you don't ever
get over this that's why i say you're
gonna feel that squeeze for the rest of
your life
and i'm glad you are it's a powerful
important memory
but she's further down the road to
healing than you are
which makes her want to hit the gas
pedal again
a lot more likely and your foot is
jammed in on that on that brake
because you've been in that car and it's
wrecked twice
and i'll be damned if i'm gonna do it
again right
and she's been in that car and it
wrecked twice and then she met with
people
and slowly took driver's education again
and got in a car with somebody else
driving for a season
and now she's ready to start driving
again right and so here's the thing
you my brother this has nothing to do
with whether you're gonna have another
kid or not
that's down the road what you have to do
is decide
i'm gonna heal not forget not toxic
positive it's all great we're
no dude but you're gonna have to decide
to let jackson
and hudson go be with the angels and
you're gonna have to
exhale and own the fact
and this is hard brother okay imagine me
and you sitting like
having a drink on the back of a tailgate
dude not just some dude on the radio
right so i'm not talking at you i'm
talking with you here you're gonna have
to decide
i'm ready to let those two boys go
they're always gonna be in my heart i'm
always gonna feel that squeeze but i
gotta let them go and i gotta heal
and more work and more busy and more
activity and more protection and bigger
walls and thicker bricks and all that
stuff isn't gonna solve that
until you decide you're gonna do that
and you and your wife
aren't shouldn't be talking about next
steps
until you've both talked through what
grieving feels like and looks like and
what you all dealt with when you haven't
dealt with
and then talk about where you are and
then talk about your son's names and
where they happen to be
and then be honest about your feelings
then be honest about the medical
challenges and then
then you're in a place to talk about
what comes next right
and right now i i it doesn't sound like
you've healed man
and if you heal hey here's the thing
devin if you heal and land on a place
that i don't want any more kids
you're allowed to do that and that's
okay and then what i would tell
your wife is if she is hell-bent on
having a
um a fourth child then it's
not about what's best for this kid
because she's gonna be bringing a kid in
a situation where dad's uncomfortable
with this
it's gonna be about i need to have a kid
i need to have a kid my guess
is that either after a healing process
you would be ready to get back on the
wagon or after a joint healing process
process together
she's going to realize that more kids
aren't in the future but right now y'all
are living parallel
different lives and there's like i say
this is fracture this is how marriages
just
drift apart over time
you know so yeah if it was just those
two because
i mean that's the only two of the deaths
we've been traumatized with since my
son's death
so i mean her brother died her sister
died from cancer my mom died from cancer
jeez it's been it's been uh
emotional roller coaster trying to
figure out how to navigate
this whole death loss but obviously
with my son it's it's a lot
personal hey hey
all of those are personal right i know
i'm i
under yeah down this boat but yes what i
mean is it's in my own
family unit that i live in with every
day
yeah that was your boy man yeah yeah
yeah
that was your boy and you're exactly
right man
and the last thing your brain and heart
and body wants you to do
is to get yet another relationship that
means something to you that you might
lose
yeah right and that's just your body
taking care of you man
it's just trying to keep the pain out
because it hurts and it hurts and it
hurts and at some point enough's enough
right
and that's the question i always want to
have for your wife too right that's
where a great
marriage counselor that you guys got to
go see about grief okay
is do we have another kid because we
think that's going to help
with the ache of this loss or are we now
healed and still and ready to add to our
family
and those are two different things
because what i'll tell you is
another child is not going to take away
the pain and the loss
it will give you joy and chaos and
mania and all the stuff that kids bring
right fun and bananas and no sleep all
that's good
but it will also not make the bad go
away
yeah and so when couples race out to
have another kid i always wanted to go
hey just breathe
just breathe because it's not going to
take that loss away
on the other side of it is when folks
are like nope never doing this again
never get back on the horse again never
never
never never here's what i'm gonna tell
you nevin i've been in this boat too
right and i was similar to you
i'm we we lost several pregnancies
one after the other after the other and
i said man i don't know
and my wife said i don't know and then
slowly we began to grieve
we had some hard conversations i didn't
know what was in her heart she didn't
know it was in mine
we finally and i did this for a living
dude and we finally sat down and we
finally
got about the business of healing and
then
as we were on the road to creating a new
tomorrow we had to create a new world a
new our world
because our current world was ash
then we created something new and said
yeah now we're ready
and then that's how we got josephine and
it's awesome
it is awesome but again that's just our
journey every journey is different
brother you gotta heal y'all aren't in a
place to be asking
should we when are we gonna have another
kid or should we have another kid y'all
are a place to
to to look at one another you just got
out of the ocean
you both saved one another and you
looked at children's are you okay
and are you okay and one of you is going
to say i'm not okay the other
needs to go i'm not either
and then you got to be about getting
well and you got to be about coming back
together and you'll have to build a
whole
new marriage and that's not a bad thing
that's a good thing and it's hard and
it's exhausting it's frustrating
that's where you all are at and then
when you see the
sidewalks laid you see some some walls
going up that's when you can look at one
another with that look and say
you down for going again and now you can
have that conversation she's just not
there yet
okay i'm so grateful for your heart
thanks for sharing this man i know
that's a hard thing to talk about it's
hard thing to share
forget about healing get about healing
brother
and it's whatever it's worth man you're
worth getting well
you old man nevin you're working well
brother and i didn't believe it either
but i was worth it my son was worth it
my wife is worth it you are too